I have 24 hours at home before I fly to New York to meet my husband,
so I decided to meal prep some things for my kids
to make meal time just a little bit easier.
Lately they've been loving pomelo,
so I prepped some of that before moving on to making some banana bread.
Mumble specifically requested chocolate in her banana bread,
so obviously I made a chocolate chip banana bread,
mashed up some ripe bananas,
added some maple syrup and egg,
some flour, gave that a really good mix before chopping up my chocolate
and also adding that. Poured it into my buttered loaf pan
and baked it for about 50 minutes to an hour before letting it cool.
In the meantime, I got started on some pizza dough.
I love having this in the fridge for a quick weeknight dinner
with some fresh tomato sauce and mozzarella.
I let that rise for about an hour and a half
while I got started on my protein option.
My mom used to make this cabbage and carrot ground beef,
which is still one of my favorite things
and now one of my kids favorites.
I sauteed my cabbage and carrot
before adding my fried up ground beef and a splash of beef stock
to that. This point
my pizza dough was ready to get portioned out and put in the fridge.
My kids have been loving an arugula salad lately,
but it has to be with a very specific lemon Dressing.
So I made some to keep in the fridge.
Just combine some lemon juice,
olive oil, salt,
pepper, some herbs.
Gave that a good mix for moving on to the last thing I was prepping,
which was a broccoli cheddar soup,
which my sister really wanted.
Sauteed my carrot, onion and celery before adding a pinch of salt,
some flour, milk,
vegetable stock, and obviously cheddar cheese.
I let that simmer, and once that came together,
I took that off the heat, and we were all good to go.